[Música]
hablamos con nuestra red de
corresponsales en directo américa y hoy
como ya lo estábamos hablando con
daniela blandón nos vamos hasta
guatemala con nuestro corresponsal de
andrés el suárez jaramillo porque avanza
la gira del presidente mexicano andrés
manuel lópez obrador por centroamérica
andrés bienvenido a este espacio matinal
de directo americano lo habíamos tenido
por aquí antes le pregunté entonces cómo
se desarrolló el encuentro de lópez
obrador con el presidente de guatemala
alejandro giammattei en ciudad de
guatemala el primer destino del
mandatario mexicano por esta gira por
cinco países
raúl un gusto saludarlo y efectivamente
la primera gira oficial al extranjero
que realiza andrés manuel lópez obrador
desde que asumió el cargo en diciembre
de 2018 ya había viajado tres veces a
eeuu pero nunca como esto inició ayer
aquí en ciudad de guatemala en donde me
encuentro a mis espaldas en el palacio
nacional fue recibido con bombos y
platillos con todos los honores le fue
dada incluso la orden del quetzal que es
la máxima condecoración que entrega el
estado de guatemala a un jefe de estado
después de estos actos protocolarios se
reunió a puerta cerrada con el
presidente alejandro giammatei las
diferentes comitivas hicieron lo mismo y
después se entregaron un reporte a los
medios una rueda de prensa en la cual el
propio giammatei le agradeció a loc por
el acuerdo de desarrollo integral
fronterizo entre la frontera sur de
méxico la frontera norte de guatemala y
ahora tendrá una nueva red ferroviaria
diferentes puestos migratorios todo
y hacer que la puerta de méxico hacia
centroamérica sea mucho más amable y
esto sobre todo porque hablo lo dijo en
palabras del banco calle
[Música]
el nuevo norte así es andrés entonces le
pregunto cuáles son los argumentos que
entrego lópez obrador en materia de
migración para llevar a cabo esta
primera gira oficial por el extranjero y
donde se espera y adonde se espera que
llegue este viernes
claro raúl y justamente es la migración
la esencia de esta gira que está
realizando lópez obrador por guatemala
el salvador honduras belice cuba el
problema migratorio para él está muy
definido y es que hay dos tipos de
emigración uno que es el optativo y otra
que es la migración forzada y esa
migración forzada es la que calificó de
dolorosa la migración en la cual las
personas huyen de la violencia huyen de
de la delincuencia de la desigualdad y
tienen que pasar penurias al norte del
río bravo de manera que dijo que es
importantísimo que esa migración se
combatan o compuestos fronterizos no con
reforzar las fronteras no con muros sino
atacando el problema de raíz lo que
significa trabajar con las comunidades y
para ello emuló diferentes programas de
gobierno que ha llevado a cabo en méxico
y que de acuerdo con él han surgido de
éxitos como el programa sembrando vida a
más de 20 mil jóvenes sembrando árboles
y árboles frutales el programa de
jóvenes construyendo futuro el programa
de 11 millones de becas de pregrado y de
postgrado para los jóvenes mexicanos el
programa plan universal de pensiones
para los mexicanos y él lo que quiere es
este tipo de políticas mexicanas
llevarlas exportarlas a los países
centroamericanos para que dentro de los
países centroamericanos se frene el
éxodo de migración sin embargo también
le hizo un reclamo muy fuerte a los eeuu
le dijo al congreso sobre todo que
desembolsillar esos 4.000 millones de
dólares que habían prometido desde la
administración trump y ahora esta gira
de andrés manuel lópez obrador
continuará en el salvador a donde
visitará al presidente nadie bukele